Я - Сергій Свириденко. Корінний донеччанин.
Колишній боєць української армії, ветеран російсько-української війни.
Нині я фермер - власник екоферми "Козацьке подвір'я".
Моя ферма розташована за 30 кілометрів від лінії розмежування - тут також можна робити бізнес.
Коли Донецьк захопили бойовики "ДНР", бізнесмен Сергій Свириденко разом з родиною
поїхав з рідного міста, а через кілька місяців пішов добровольцем у військо.
Після звільнення зі служби навесні 2016 року переселенець-ветеран
заснував екоферму "Козацьке подвір'я"
- на колишній дачі у селі Іванопілля, яка після втечі з Донецька
стала для Сергія і його сім'ї домом.
От так ми їх адаптуємо до наших диких умов. Щоб відразу розуміли, куди вони потрапили.
Зараз вони подивляться, що тут до чого, вилізуть на берег, знайдуть, де тут їжа.
Хвилюються - це поки що. І почнеться у них нове життя.
Не в якомусь там сараї, а на природі - як і має бути.
От - пішли, потихесеньку. Чим складніший початок життя,
тим легше буде їхнє життя надалі.
Непростим був початок на новому місці у Сергія. Вчитися доглядати тварин, варити сир
і готувати м'ясні делікатеси довелося практично "з нуля" -
раніше ніхто з родини не фермерував.
Щоправда, життєвий досвід таки став у нагоді. Адже Сергій - професійний кухар,
працював за фахом навіть у Португалії.
А після повернення в Донецьк разом з дружиною Сніжаною
займався бізнесом - торгували ковбасою.
Зараз маємо стадо зі ста кіз - це разом із цапами. 35 качок було - маточне стадо.
Зараз їх тут дуже багато - ніхто не рахує і немає сенсу рахувати.
Кози дають молоко для сиру, коров'яче молоко ми купляємо у наших сусідів.
У тих людей, що возять молоко, ми беремо і свиней - адже знаємо,
що ці свині вигодовані сироваткою.
Це дуже класне м'ясо - якісне.
На початку на фермі було лише шість кіз - купили у місцевої бабусі.
А сир варили просто на кухні.
Розширити господарство і побудувати сироварню допомогли гранти.
Спершу Сергій, надавши вдалий бізнес-план, отримав допомогу
за державною програмою "Український донецький куркуль".
А згодом - підтримку від Програми розвитку ООН і чешської організації "Людина в біді".
Нині у бізнесі зайнята вся родина. Син працює у невеличкій крамниці ферми на ринку у Дружківці.
Донька - варить сир. Також на "Козацькому подвір'ї" - вже шість найманих працівників.
Одна поїхала в Київ, одна точно в Хмельницький. Ця на Умань їде.
Хлопці там на "Новій пошті" сміються - кажуть: "Опять балалайку принесли?"
- Кажу: "Так, тільки нашу українську - свинячу".
Сири і м'ясні делікатеси Сергій і його дружина Сніжана продають
головним чином на ярмарках і через Інтернет.
По всій країні - крім окупованої території, на якій опинилося і їхнє місто Донецьк.
Ми разом торгували ковбасою - а потім "руський мир" прийшов до Донецька.
І ми разом перестали торгувати. Бо в нас уже забрали все, що було
- і базу, і ковбасу, і все на світі.
Добре, що ми на машинах хоч змогли виїхати з дітьми - неушкоджені.
Але ж без одягу, без нічого... Думали, пересидимо тут трохи - і все буде добре.
Ми з жінкою постійно брали участь у наших проукраїнських мітингах у Донецьку
- і сподівалися, що Донецьк залишиться Україною.
Не було переважної кількості сепаратистів в Донецьку - якщо було, то, може, 30 відсотків.
Якщо б наші люди, які хотіли, щоб лишилась Україна, всі вийшли - не було б такого.
Але бачите - не вийшли. Думали - так пройде, нормально буде. Не сталося.
У Донецьку в Сергія і Сніжани залишився не тільки бізнес і нерухомість.
Через свою проукраїнську позицію родина втратила багато друзів.
Я майже не спілкуюся зі своїм рідним братом. Сергій зі своїм братом зовсім не спілкується.
Це все трапилось у 14-му році. Політична воля така сталась - і ми розділились.
Але ж ми знайшли багато нових друзів. І ті нові сьогодні - один за десятьох.
Багато ходило - кричали "Руський мир!" Накричались?
А як кажуть: "А страдаєт простой народ".
"Ми такі прості, ми не винні, це все політики!" Ганебна це практика - так думати і робити.
Спочатку за гречку голосуємо, а потім політики винуваті.
І нам залишається брати бандуру і співати жалісних пісень про важку долю.
Як ві думаєте, вам вдасться знайти спільну мову з вашими друзями?
Це їхня проблема - не моя. Я батьківщину не зраджував.
Вони захочуть знайти спільну мову - хай вони зі мною шукають, а не я з ними.
Утім, до Донецька подружжя не збирається повертатися навіть після деокупації -
хіба що погостити на декілька днів.
Кажуть, що звикли до нового життя - стали селянами і жити в місті вже не хочуть.
Планують розбудовувати ферму і розвивати на Донеччині сільський туризм.
Доброго дня, вітаю! - Здравствуйте!
Сергій. - Анна. - Дуже приємно. -
До вас приїхали - завітали. -
Добре, правильно зробили.
Проходьте, заходьте, будь ласочка.
Як у вас гарно.